the aforementioned Pat 40 the college
football writer columnist for Yahoo
Sports who joins us now Pat good morning
how are you I'm good just coming out a
little drive-through hernia surgery I
missing hard to slow down and actually
go to the hospital so you know Todd's a
little soft I'm not gonna well fritzie's
having double hernia surgery I mean you
had one right yeah yes he is doubling
the fun for sure um although I you know
I I don't know what all is involved in
double hernia surgery that makes it
harder than single heart surgery if they
if he could have a triple hernia surgery
that's probably next for him knowing
Fritzi all right the committee rationale
what do you think is the most important
thing when that community gets together
and they start to look at everybody's
body of work what is and what should be
the number one thing they look at I
think it's resume Dan um and I think it
should be resume you know I think I
don't want a committee that goes in
there and watches film and says you know
the way they're they're inside zone
blocking is they they should be able to
beat one I don't want them to predict
who's going to win a match up I want
them to look at the resumes what they've
done and yes you can use I test as far
as who's played the best and impressed
you the most but but I want to pick the
four best teams based on what they have
actually seen them do as opposed to
predicting what they might do in a
playoff did they do that with the latest
rankings I believe so uh it's a little
bit scary to me because I have poked a
lot of fun at the committee but my one
through eight is the exact same is there
one to eight in order hmm um I guess
we're trying to figure out the and and I
I know it's a reality show my guy I
brace for a reality show here it's just
like the NCAA tournament they somehow
get a coach who's facing the school that
he used to coach at but that hey they
didn't plan it that way it just would
always happen that you know somehow that
would happen and that's why I look at
this it's only for schools but are we
looking at how Ohio State plays
nationally or do
you have Lamar Jackson and Louisville in
there are they big enough do we want to
see a Heisman Trophy winner does that
factor in at all with human beings
picking out these four schools well it's
interesting because as you mentioned the
reality show part of it I think is what
we don't we go through in November where
it's just like hey let's throw Texas A&M
in there that would be kind of fun you
know it's all just screwing around in
the first few weeks because none of it
matters which is why I'm not a big fan
of the weekly show because they're
basically yanking the chains of various
overly emotional love football fans here
was their ranking true then when the
rubber hits the road at the end maybe
that is the case you know how state
getting in over TCU and Baylor that
first year certainly who was them who
had more appeal it was the bigger draw
most does Lamar Jackson carry weight you
know if it comes down to an either/or
with at the end of this thing if if
you're looking to break a theoretical
tie for fourth does having the
presumptive Heisman Trophy winner and
the most exciting player people have
seen in a few years carry the day I
don't know but I would bet that it's at
least discussed I think it should at
least be discussed and they need be shot
down but fine but at least talk about it
the fan base most likely to get left on
the outside looking in a zoo I'd say
Louisville I think that resume is a
little bit short right now and they need
some stuff to happen it can't happen you
know if Michigan losses and kind of
accuses itself and then you have a
two-loss Big Ten Champion that's not
Ohio State I think Louisville could
sneak in as the second team from the ACC
but as of right now you know they beat
the snot out of Florida State they have
a very close exciting loss to Clemson
they have the best player in the country
but that's about it they didn't get a
good set of opponents from the other
division in the ACC so they're acc
schedule is not great and their
non-conference schedules not great does
the last five years hurt Penn State in
any way shape or form on and off the
field don't think so now yeah i don't i
don't think so i think that's immaterial
should be a material I don't think
that's the kind of thing the committee
should should factor
at all it's not their job you know what
the that's a is a matter that was always
too important for the NCAA it was a
matter for the courts mostly and then
the secondly the NC double-a did get
involved and screwed it up so maybe
lessons were learned let's just look at
this make a football decision had 40
yahoo sports college football columnist
Jones Dan Patrick show biggest game
aside from Ohio state-michigan the rest
of the year that could impact the top
four is what uh you know i would say
probably the apple cup washington
washington state which is not something
you say every year yes so it's shaping
up i mean washington state's right now
they lead that division they're
undefeated in the pac-12 north but if
Washington can win that game and then
win the pac-12 championship and was sit
there with what was a one-loss
conference champion that played 10
league games do they get left out in
favor of a second team from either the
ACC or the Big Ten that would be a big
big argument the biggest disappointment
this year was oh my gosh there been a
lot of them uh I would have to say
Oregon nah no you know what I'll say
Michigan State Michigan State because I
expected Oregon to take a big step back
this year not just not as far as they
did but Michigan State I really didn't
think that you know I thought they were
on a path where they're going to win
nine ten eleven games every single year
and they just fell apart completely I
mean the only team they have beaten in
September 1517 is his Rutgers and
everybody beats records so it's just
been an absolute train wreck up there
with a program that I thought was really
built to last so that one's shocked me
the most can they relegate Rutgers like
they do in the Premier League they can
you put North Dakota State or how about
Western Michigan gets to be in the Big
Ten playing football for a year I think
I'll be right I would love it you know
what and yet Delaney can you know he's
he was so happy with his his new york TV
market i guess he can ngoba count the
sub sub cable subscription to the big
ten network in the new york area while
waiting for Rutgers to resume being
competitive and moved back up where are
you this weekend
I'm at home there's a bad look here we
go Pat 40 now all of a sudden we mail it
in sit in front of the TV you can be a
sports columnist for yahood you can just
sit at home and watch TV okay pet you
come sit with me Danity notes together
you don't have enough beer for me pen we
can try thank you bud thank you i pad 40
yahoo sports the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience